yeah it isn't
thank you so uh good afternoon everyone
and welcome to the audit
and corporate governance scrutiny
committee
so item one apologies for abstinence
please
um i've not received any chair but
before we start i just informed members
that we're
going live to youtube streaming my
council's website i'm also just going to
record this meeting for the
purposes of the minute so you just hear
a prompt
this meeting is being recorded thank you
chad
thank you so no apologies received so we
moved to item two declarations of
interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interest
and or other interests not already on
their register of interest
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting at the appropriate time
moving to item three minutes of the last
meeting
meeting held on the 20th of january 2021
those papers have been circulated so
could we have a proposal please that
they are true and accurate record
yeah i'll propose it thank you council
armitage do you have a second there
i'll second it martin thank you
councillor kerry
seconded by council kerry all in favor
thank you that is carried thank you so
item for the
report of the external auditors of mazar
so
over to uh to you mr norman so
everybody um just a short report from us
to update you on the external audits uh
so
talking if i could to page four of our
reports
which page 11 of the the the bigger
documents and
on that page what we're confirming is
that the uh
the audit for 1920s is now complete
there are no additional items to
to bring to your attention and we've
we've issued the annual audit letter
uh which uh which went out in december
uh at the time the report was written
there were two uh
other pieces of work related to 1920
which were in progress
which was set out in the in h4
uh clearly to confirm on that that the
pooling claim was submitted
uh with no acceptance at the end of
january
and the works on going on the housing
benefit uh
we're working on the 2021 audit
at the moment pulling together the
planning and the audit strategy memo
and we'll present that to the audience
governance committee at its next meeting
there are no no significant changes in
the scope of the audit or the overall
risk profile of the
uh of the audit at this stage uh again
as in 1920 we expect to carry out the
audit
remotely uh unless the the operator the
working arrangement
uh change that was largely successful
but well it was successful last year i
mean there were clearly some
difficulties
as you'd expect we managed to to
mitigate those with with managers
uh page five of our documents gives us
some information which we will say more
on in the audit strategy more in the
april meeting
uh about the changes to the value from
any approach
for this year rather unhelpfully the
guidance from national audit office
has been issued late and is incomplete
um so we're picking those threads
together
as as we speak but as i say we will say
more on that
and and give more information to the
committee at this next meeting in our
entire report and then finally
uh in section two we've just given out a
summary of um
some of the more recent
current documents which are irrelevant
to your role
um building governance
kind of areas i think the only two are
probably
flagged which are picked up elsewhere on
the agenda are
um that the the code of the county's
practice
guidance and disclosure notes have been
published
uh and jane's report later on on
accounting policies picks up on the
the model policies which are broadly
consistent with the
um the the models policies in the in the
code
and then there's this sit for
publication relating to the head of
internal audit opinions which is picked
up in jenny's report
so clearly don't be saying any more on
that
but that's the reflection of that um the
impact that covert has had on delivery
of some of the internal audit plans for
this year
so that's all the only points i wanted
to flag on our reports
um i said we will say more in our
distracting moment to the next meeting
but i'm happy to
to do with any questions if there are
any at this stage
thank you are there any comments or
questions
well that's it then mr norman thank you
for
the progress report and technical update
so um
i think we just need to from a committee
point of view note
the the report so can we have a proposal
for that please
thank you council rowe seconded by
council club
all in favor
thank you that is carried thank you mr
norman for your time this afternoon
thank you uh we move on to item five
reporter the internal audit consortium
manager over to you please jenny
hello thank you chair um so this report
summarises the
audits we've completed since the last
meeting
and gives you a progress update on the
2021
internal audit plan um so turning to
appendix one
this period we've issued five reports
and you can see that they're all
substantial assurance that's our top
category so that's um
an excellent set of results and i don't
have any specific concerns to raise with
you
there was no evidence of any fraud
taking place in the areas that we looked
at
um in terms of the 2021 internal audit
plan
it is clear that we won't be able to
complete the whole of the plan
and but given the circumstances i think
we have made good progress
um the areas we don't complete will be
considered for inclusion in the 21 22 in
order internal audit plan uh depending
on the
results of our risk assessment and
discussions with key officers
um so dependence four that provides
details of the audits we've completed
and those we've still got to do um i
have a
discuss with the 151 officer and risk
management group any other potential
risks we need to cover this year
and at the moment we don't feel the need
to vary the plan but i am keeping that
under constant review
and again any high-risk areas will be
built into 21-22 audit plans
um i also wanted to bring your attention
to the guidance that safer have issued
and that's appendix 3 and that's in
relation to the head of internal audits
annual opinion and avoiding a limited
scope
um so each year i have to give an audit
opinion on the governance risk
management and controls in place
and to avoid a limited scope we need to
have covered sufficient work
and there isn't any definition of what
constitutes sufficient work it's down to
professional opinion
um i've looked at the plan closely and
what we've done so far and what we
anticipate doing by the end of march
i'm happy that we'll be able to give an
unlimited uh conclusion
we won't have covered as much as usual
but we will be
able to provide um some assurance in the
key areas of governance risk management
to control
um and without i'll try and answer any
questions chair thank you
thank you any comments or questions
no no comments or questions i think um
i think it's good to see that uh the sip
for
guidance that's the latest one from
november 2020 has been incorporated and
you've made reference to that and um
thank you very much for your comments on
that as well so
as far as i'm concerned we can move to
recommendations to
six 6.1 6.2 can we have someone move the
recommendations please
thank you councillor clough to have a
second up please council armitage thank
you all in favor
thank you that's carried so we we next
move
to um item six
reporter the information engagement and
performance manager that's the uh
quarter three report oh would you please
kath okay thank you very much chair
okay so as you can see members can see
from the covering report
of the 74 targets for q3 uh 45 of those
are on track
uh 21 have been affected by covid
two have been achieved behind target
three are overdue
one we've left on alert and is unlikely
to be achieved in 2021
and two have been achieved this quarter
just to pull out a few things from the
report
regarding target eco 20
under 1.3 of your covering report
uh just to note there um
that that the restructuring report is
continuing to that is going to go to
informal cabinet to secure resource
but by way of reassurance for members
the tourism strategy has now been
approved
um there is an operating budget for this
type of work which obviously it needs
there's an intern in place
until the end of march and projects have
already been identified
to move this whole piece of work forward
so good to know that this is moving
forward
moving on to our environment we've left
target and number five on alert
as noted at q2 uh the target lead is not
expecting this target to be achieved
this year
they continue to work the enforcement
team continues to work proactively with
relevant departments when
enforcement issues arise but they're not
in the position
due to capacity and recruitment issues
to do two proactive
exercises obviously that's not ideal but
that's
an honest update of the current position
and then we've noted once again there's
a couple of targets there
that's been affected by kobe and members
will find the narrative in the appendix
that's covering that
under our residence just to note that uh
target number 10 has been achieved uh
the target was to achieve at least a
thousand
direct communications with a thousand
residents by december 20 and it's good
to know that over four and a half
thousand
residents have actually signed up to
receive direct electronic communication
so
the campaign to recruit people has been
there very good there so that's a
positive development
and then under services uh just to note
under
target number 18 uh review the council's
petition scheme by annual council 2020.
obviously that was delayed last year due
to covid
uh the monitoring officers agreed with
the leader that that will be taken
forward in the new civic year
so that'll be a piece of work that will
be done then
and just to know that the planning
enforcement protocol
um has been and that's noted as overdue
and i've just had an email this
afternoon from richard purcell to say
that that has
been published so we will clarify that
after the meeting what the status of
this target is but i'm thinking that
actually this target is
not overdue it's actually been completed
but i'll clarify that and make sure our
records are up to date
and then there's a couple there that's
been achieved uh and then as i've said
there's still quite a few targets
affected by
covid and they're noted in the appendix
so i won't go into the details of though
now
of those now we've tried to get very
up-to-date
updates so that members have got some
level of reassurance about what
activities are going forward and
and what things have been directly
affected so that concludes the report
chair
thank you any comments or questions
[Music]
councillor barker
thanks for that cather and i think
overall
it's it's a good report i think given
given that covenant and everything else
uh
it's a good performance there's just a
couple of questions that have
i've made a note of on page 47 just the
local plan
it says that it's on it's on track are
we sure about that
this is my question uh given that
uh it's i don't know where we're at with
it regarding the consultation and stuff
and the other ones on page 51
uh and again i i suppose i am
a bit uh reduce the annual subsidy of
the ledger services year on year
i just wondered how the killer marsh
leisure center fits into that when we
taking on more subsidy oh
that's they may do questions right okay
i haven't got the detailed answers to
those two questions
uh obviously the information in the
appendix is the opinion of the officer
when we collected the update at the end
of december but by all means i can go
back
and clarify um or seek assurance
on the local plan that this statement
and give some extra
explanation around that so i'll do that
after the meeting councillor bark would
feed that information back to you
and i'll do the same with the killer
marsh one as well
and go back to the target lead to raise
that issue regarding
how that fits into that update as well
okay
thank you could i ask kath as well that
you copied me into that email as chair
of this committee
yeah that's absolutely fine no problem
council marker won't mind
um
[Laughter]
of interest to the entire committee so
yes by all means we'll copy you in his
chair
thank you my question relates to page 48
um of course the environment
alert at page 48 which makes reference
to the capacity and recruitment
issues i'm obviously assuming it's 20
20 stroke 21 21 21
um i'm just wondering um
about this because we've been talking
about um capacity issues for some time
now with regard to enforcement
um it's not just something that's been
creeping on on us for
last few months all of us as councillors
would say that
we've had planning enforcement issues
within our wards and
we've needed capacity to be able to deal
with it
now the recruitment process as i'm aware
was first
considered quite a while ago
and yet it's referred to almost as
though it's a relatively recent issue
that's cropped up so
i'm not convinced it is relatively
recent and i wouldn't also
um agree that any recruitment issues
have been hampered by covid because
there are lots of organizations who
continue to recruit
through the pandemic so i'm just
considering here what information we
could glean from
that department about how they are
working hard to address the recruitment
side of things and how they are managing
planning enforcement during this time
i think the best thing is let me go back
to the header service so that we can
i think you'd be useful to have a full
update there so you've got some bullet
points on progress
how it's been tracked through that
department um
so more operational detail to probably
expect
the generic update in the report so once
again i'll do that after the meeting
yeah and the interests and consistency
if you copy the chair of the committee
on that as well okay
that's myself
i know you just tried you just tried to
trick me i'm following i know i need to
cover here
i'm just going to copy you into
everything i think that's the safest
option
that's our heritage yeah uh as regards
the
enforcement we've uh
we've got a number in nashoba which have
been investigated and
as i understand it uh we've
brought people in from other areas to
try
and cover the whole but as yet
i know there was a an advert went out
for enforcement officers
uh some time ago and there were no
uh suitable recipients uh and a new one
has just recently gone out
and i'm not sure of its progress at the
moment
but there does seem to be uh a lacking
in uh enforcement officers and also
planning officers and you know
considering that these
people are well uh town and country
uh planning graduates are turned out by
uh
universities every year there doesn't
seem to be anybody coming forward
that's as much as i can understand
thank you councilman as i say kath's
going to make sure that
we get a detailed response from the
environment
with regard to that any other comments
or questions
no so if we could move then to the
recommendations at 6.1
come someone move them please
thank you council armitage do you have a
second
council row thank you very much all
those in favor
thank you so that's accepted and thank
you cath for your report
so item seven reporter the director of
corporate resources and head of paid
service on
risk management and over to the section
151 officer
sorry about that everyone uh technical
issues in the chamber and we're sharing
a microphone because we know that this
one works can everybody hear me okay
yep great i'm obviously not lee as
you'll as you'll realize lee's actually
on leave this week so i've off to bring
this report so
i won't know as much about this as lee
but i'll probably be a lot quicker than
me you'll be welcome you'll be pleased
to know
and it's just to update you the
quarterly update on the order
and corporate governance scrutiny to
update the committee
on the current position regarding risk
management so
what these put together is an update
from the meeting that took place on the
16th of december which
talked through all of the strategic
risks it talked through the operational
risks in a particular service area and
it took soundings from as jenny
mentioned in her talk
and it took sandings from the head of
internal order
went through emergency planning business
continuity planning etc etc
all the details in the report i will
endeavor to answer any questions but if
i can't i will take them away and ask
lee
to update you after the meeting thank
you chair
thank you are there any comments or
questions about the report
non so if we could move then to the
recommendations are you asking the
question council barker yeah just to
comment yeah
yeah and
[Music]
i just like the format i don't know
seems to be
better i don't know the the with the
mitigations and
stuff at side i don't know if i missed
it but but this format seems to be a lot
clearer than
some we've had in the past so
i think that's that's good and and like
you say i think you've
they've covered most of the risks thank
you
thank you i think um i hope the
committee would agree with council
barca's comments as well i think the
format
in that table
okay easy to assimilate
so thank you for that so recommendations
and at 6.1
can we have a a mover for the
recommendations please thank you council
club do you have a seconder
thank you council dayton all in favor
what's the simulate mean i'll buy you a
dictionary for christmas council barker
so uh that's carried
um moving on to item eight reporter the
head
of the head of finance and resources and
section 151 officer
quarter three financial monitoring would
you please jane
thank you chair back in my comfort zone
i can talk about finance i do struggle
to talk about risk i have to say
this is to update the committee on the
quarter three position
and you'll note at 1.1 of the cabinet
report this is to bring the
the cabinet report that will go on the
4th of march to the audit committee for
scrutiny before it goes to cabinet so
any comments will be
will be welcomed and presented to the
cabinet on that date
so i'll mainly be referring to the
appendix which is the cabinet report
you'll note in 1.1 we talk about the
pandemic
and it's still having an impact on the
budget but we did take account of most
of that as part of the revised budget
that this committee saw way back in
october
um we're estimating at the moment that
we're going to be losing
around about 2 million pounds worth of
income and at the end of december it was
1.376
so it's on track not good on track but
on track to where we expected it to be
conversely we have received 1.44 million
pounding grants from the government thus
far
and we continue to make claims under the
income compensation scheme
and to the end of november we've
reclaimed 797
000 predominantly leisure services
we've taken account of all the income
and expenditure and the cash flow
positions
throughout the year remained at a pretty
healthy level we've done some forward
forecasting and
aren't anticipating any problems with
cash flow now until the end of the year
um detailed at appendix one's the
general fund summary
it's pretty much on budget which you
would expect at quarter three because
we've literally just done a revised
budget so we don't tend to get many
variances of note at this point
but just want to flag with you that
planning fees have remained at
pre-pandemic levels
right throughout this year and are
already higher than the forecast
that we made back in october and that's
generating
generating the surplus on the general
fund
in terms of the hra very static nothing
to report of note
renting comes slightly down but
absolutely nothing of concern 34 000 on
a 30 million pound budget really nothing
overly for us to worry about and the
capital programme
is down on the hra largely because we
couldn't complete the works at the
beginning of the year because of the
pandemic it was difficult to carry out
some of the works
we don't think we'll catch that back up
or ricknord homes don't think they'll
catch that back up but they are doing
everything they can to
to undertake what they can appendix 5
covers
the treasury management strategy it's
really just an update of the indicators
and nothing more than that
and at that point i'm happy to take
questions chair any comments or
questions
councillor barker
88 or page two of your cabinet report
at the bottom one 1.12 about the
uh vacancy savings
uh 173
000 have have started to come in is that
am i reading that right it couldn't be
total
0.173 million
uh i mean i've asked this and i'd asked
i'd ask you when
when when we were in control that's all
well and good but what
effects is that having on service
delivery and
where are the savings coming from it's
all right just having uh
uh not not filling posts but that
can have an effect on what we do that
supposes me question
and and is it impacting on that
you're absolutely right councillor barco
year on year on year on year we we
generate these vacancy savings which
we don't budget for because we want a
full establishment you know
we all take measures to reduce post
permanently out of the establishment if
we can manage without
them so these are posts that we've
identified as needing
and then we have vacancy savings which
that they're not real savings because
they go back in the budget the following
year so
it they're only ever one-offs and
they're almost certainly going to have
some impact on the on the um
performance of the services i've not
nothing's been flagged particularly to
me about that but it's certainly
something that we should probably take
to some as a as an observation from this
committee and i'm happy to do that for
you
thank you any other comments or
questions
mine's still with variance in budget um
you mentioned that um
some figures might be here and there
in the big scheme of things but when you
add them up
there might be a a big thing to think
about now for example
if we looked at environment protection
the variance is 60
000 if i'm looking on page ninety three
the variance is sixty thousand then
you've got the materials recycling
variants at fifty thousand before you
know it that's a hundred and ten
thousand
you could go through all of it and start
to add them up and before you know it
the
quarter million and so on um why do we
have some of those
variances that i would say the big
scheme of things are things that we
need to be considering like
environmental protection and materials
recycling
you're absolutely you're absolutely
right chair the the variances are up and
down all over the place and then they
come back to an overall total so
you're absolutely right if you took all
the pluses and all the minuses you'd end
up with a very different position to the
net position
and in terms of materials recycling that
is a budget pressure for that shadow of
a doubt
um i need to speak to the camera sorry
i'm waving my head all over the place
the um i'm looking at one screen looking
at another sorry that's a diversion
tactic
no it's not really um yeah the materials
recycling budget is under pressure
something was brought to my attention
just yesterday that that is
um is an issue that we need to keep an
eye on
um i can't guarantee that that won't be
a budget pressure at the end of the year
but
you're absolutely right to raise it that
is a budget pressure right
that wasn't identified as part of the
review
will budget pressures then be identified
at the cabinet meeting when you meet
with them so that there can be a
steer from cabinet about budget
pressures
and will there then be feedback to us as
a committee
about how they intend to address budget
pressures that
have led to a variance of that type
i could certainly i can certainly flag
that with the cabinet at the meeting for
your chair with pleasure
thank you council barker
just just done that to chair martin just
look further down
if we look at street cleaning service
transport
there's this there's three or four in a
row there
domestic waste collection and and that
sort of fits into that
category doesn't it be quite small
numbers on their own but you add them
all up
that's a lot and that just does does
that causes any concerns
it doesn't cause me any concern those
particular variants is councillor barca
because okay
i can explain what the majority of those
are the majority of those are the
vacancy savings that
were reported earlier at 1.12
it's just look that i do know exactly
what those three are because i looked at
them when i was when i was scrutinizing
this before i
presented the report um but you're
absolutely right those vacancies those
vacancy savings there
must be been offset by costs elsewhere
and as the chair quite rightly pointed
out one of those is materials recycling
so so you do have those ups and downs
within the budget
yeah i think sometimes it swings and
roundabouts if you took
street scene for example as one section
and you looked at all the the variances
some that are positive some are negative
in the big scheme of things you could
say some of it balances but
when that you do get some that are
wildly
more variant than you first thought and
they start to contribute to the bigger
picture
of you know budgetary issues here
then of course those conversations need
to be had either with the head of that
department
or the cabinet member concerned or the
cabinet as a whole
or us as a scrutiny committee and
having these um questions and answer
sessions so that we can get to the the
number of what the problem is if there
is a problem
jane if i may just comment here we do we
do do a lot of internal budget
monitoring as well so a lot of these
variances although
although they may have happened because
budget monitoring by its nature is
retrospective it's after it's happened
what it does it puts it on our radar to
then be able to
to flag with the manager to flag with
the head of the service
and the portfolio holder where there are
potentially pressures that need to be
dealt with and that's exactly what's
happened with the materials recycling
just to offer you a little bit of
comfort thank you yes and obviously we
would expect there would be internal
discussions and so on but we are the
scrutiny committee
and we scrutinize and we have to ask
these questions in turn as well
and if you've got the answers that's
great and if you need to have further
discussion
then that's what has to happen too
so any other comments or questions
if not then we move the recommendations
at 6.1 can we have someone move those
please
thank you council rowe and seconded by
council club all those in favor
thank you that's carried thank you the
next one is corporate debt
i wish you please jane thank you chair
this is the report that we bring on a
quarterly basis that reports the
corporate debt position this is the
corporate debt position of the 31st
of december and again no major areas of
concern or note and this is probably why
our cash flow is holding up
relatively well um so i wasn't going to
go through any detail but i'm more than
happy to take questions
any comments or questions please
council barca
just a question really on on page 107
or whatever number seven at the 5
million pound current debt position
that that that's not a problem to you
then and i know there's some like
more uh present you know that that will
come in
but that that is a big figure five
million
am i reading that right you are
councillor bar krenit is a a very big
figure a large proportion of that is the
recharges between us and bowls over
and then bills with the county and the
like so a lot of it's local authority
debt
so sorry can you hear me is that better
yes yeah i've got you i will
i get a bit of an echo so i'm never sure
if you can hear me or not
a lot of it's local authority debt so
what i could do for next meeting if it
would help is i'll separate out the two
because
five million is an awful lot if it's not
save money if you like
you know money and inter-authority money
is generally
um payable and so i'll do that for you
for next time
thank you and my comment it relates to
overpaid housing benefit
and you may recall i asked this years
ago
in them scrutiny committee and
my concern is that when we overpay
housing benefit ultimately the person
then has to pay that back
and that's not a good position for
someone to be in when they realize that
the money that they thought was theirs
and sorted and so on
then becomes an issue for them it's like
when you get a tax bill
and you think you're sorted for the year
then suddenly you get another one that
says
i overpaid you you better pay it back
and it puts all of your
your reckonings and everything out of
order so it's i don't think
it's a good position for us to be in to
be overpaying someone and then
seeking to have it back and it's a
substantial amount of money
um any comment on that at all
yes chair you're absolutely right it is
a substantial account amount of money
it's something that um
we've actually got an action in our
action plan this year our reps and
revenues and benefits teams action plan
to have a look at this
a lot of that is historic a lot of it's
been there as you will know for
for many many years and we need a
strategy for dealing with that old debt
um and it was something that i'll bring
to the committee hopefully sometime
during the next financial year
and we do take every measure that we
possibly can to make sure that we don't
overpay people there's lots of robust
procedures in place but
sometimes people just don't tell us the
circumstances have changed and then that
leads to the overpayments which can be
quite
quite challenging we are sympathetic to
that and we you know we'd never want to
see anybody in any sort of difficulty so
we always
um work with them to to work a payment
plan forward that's
both affordable to them and acceptable
to us um but you're absolutely right
that that figure
has concern for me as well and so we've
tried to address it yeah well
i'm a great believer that if people are
entitled to benefit that's what they
should receive
and but when you're into a position of
overpayment and then we're pursuing them
for
for it back and that puts people into
more financial difficulties
it's not good for their mental health
and well-being and for where they're at
so i think the council has to
pay what is correct and so i'm going to
recommend that we add a 6.2
to the recommendations and that is to
receive further information
including action planning with regard to
overpaid housing benefit
are we happy with that additional
recommendation
[Music]
i'm getting the thumbs up from the
majority of folks so i'm going to say
yes to that so
are there any other comments or
questions about the report
if not can we move to the
recommendations so we've got 6.1 and the
addition
of 6.2 can we have a mover for those
please
yeah i'll move it thank you council
armitage and second by councillor club
all those in favor thank you carried and
we moved to the next report on the
proposed accounting policies for 20 20
21
would you please jane
thank you again chair i can't believe
we're actually doing the accounting
policies for 2021 already
it's it's actually yeah it's the end of
the year almost already
um it doesn't seem five minutes since we
were starting last year
um but there's very very little change
i'm happy to report this time
um cypher have been kind to us as mike
mentioned in his speech
earlier the code has been released there
are very very few changes in the zip for
code this year
and certainly nothing of note that's
going to affect our accounts so
so these accounting policies are almost
identical to the ones that were
presented to this
committee this time last year and i'm
happy to take
any questions chair any comments or
questions
nope move to the recommendations end at
6.1 and 6.2
can we have a mover please
council row thank you and do we have a
second
council armitage thank you all in favor
thank you that's carried and then item
nine reporter the head of corporate
governance and monitoring officer
on the corporate work program for twenty
twenty twenty one
yesterday report um just outlines the
committee's work program for remainder
of the municipal year and it's just to
to know and approve the work program
and any comments or questions
now i think the outline seems fine to me
and we keep adjusting it as you know
as we go along so we always find some
things to add
and i'm sure we'll continue to do it as
well but uh
since there's no comments or questions
we'll move to recommendations at item 6
6.1
can we have a mover for those please
counselor i'm looking at you because
you've been working hard on that this
afternoon
thank you second by council club thank
you all in favor
thank you that's carried um item 10
forward plan of executive decisions
any comments on any of those now i think
um
the link is there so i'm sure you're all
vigilant and looking at those
i think it's just noted because no one's
raised any comments or questions so item
11 then to consider any other
items which the chairs of the opinion
should be considered as a matter of
urgency there are none
so item 12 date of next meeting which as
you can see
is the 28th of april 2021
and i thank you very much for your
attendance and declare the meeting
closed thank you
you